[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live iron law
podcast lords of gaming dot net lord
cognito here in the realm of fact east
and who is this fine gentleman in the
round today what's your name sir uh
billy really cool and what developer
publisher for uh publisher for marvelous
usa awesome awesome and what is this
game we have here what's going on i
think it's on your channel
what's this game we're talking about uh
this is deadcraft uh it's a survival
action game that also have like farming
simulator okay okay so survival action
and some farming simulator aspects yeah
we got lord attic doing the gameplay
today so we're checking it out right now
and i'm just curious about again
the premise anything about the storyline
why are we here what we're doing any
information in regards to that in
regards to that craft
uh this is the setting is
post-apocalyptic so every like
this
yes the setting it's kind of it's like
similar to like something like mad max
okay okay yeah
settings in the desert um
this guy's
out for revenge for someone like killing
his friend and right now he's just
trying to survive yeah
gotcha guys you got your survival on so
i'm seeing your energy bar i'm seeing we
have a map system kind of like that so
are we having
full rpg mechanics we talking to people
like what's the kind of like the
gameplay loop so to speak in in this
game as far as dead craft um it's pretty
much just uh going around talking to
people trying to get items of build like
build a zombie army and
get like getting into the city so like
you can fight like all the like all your
enemies god [ __ ] how's that control
looking at it how's it feeling the
controller feels nice i don't know where
this controller is but i need to fix my
life addict like the control you feeling
it you know what i'm saying it's also
giving me a wasteland three kind of odds
with the over top kind of thing so again
and as far as on support now
very responsive so single-player game
yes
gosh you got you and um as far as
release as far as platforms what are we
looking out for uh it's going to be on
ps ps5 ps4
xbox
uh switch and steve oh wow multiple
platforms yeah
awesome awesome yeah it look really
looks good to see it as we traverse on
yeah she got the little faction action
going on so i'm seeing you got your
basic energy bar your health and then
your energy bar so what were kind of
like the things that would kind of
deplete
that that type of stuff oh yeah um so
he's he has a meter where it's like half
zombie half human okay the zombie side
gives you like zombie like abilities and
the more the more you use your zombie
abilities the more it starts draining
your zombie all right
now you're getting excited what's this
zombie stuff so basically the character
can invoke zombies is isn't like what's
going on yeah he's a half half zombie
like cute half human okay
and yeah
yeah what's the shield
okay okay what are we doing now break
this down
this is cool this is cool yeah so every
time you use those like zombie moves
like that you start losing your meter
and yeah you just you just hit the top
people don't want no smoke yeah no
problems with this yeah the fact that
you're in town you hit a civilian you
kind of made everyone your enemy because
now they've known that you're a zombie i
like that though yeah
consequences so based on your actions
now this would affect the ai in terms of
the towns that he goes to yeah okay
gotcha now could he could he basically
approach that situation differently if
he didn't do it like attack like what
would be the advantage of not attacking
oh they won't be hitting me yeah they'll
be the first everyone's not trying to
kill you and if you
want like try you're trying to do a
quest trying to make money like like
don't they'll talk god [ __ ] she got so
basic so now here's the thing though
with basic questing if like he kills
that town and stuff like that you
eliminate those abilities as far as like
shopkeepers and things forever is that
that oh no it can respond if you like
watch it like leave and go home gotcha
and that's like usually like how you
have to avoid it so like if you run if
you run away from everyone far enough
the the wanted meter will go down
so that we so we have a wanted meter
like a wanted system yeah gotchu okay
got it got it now as far as like levels
level design
how do we know about approximately like
how long gameplay hours we're looking at
for this game uh is it a fully is it
like you know trying to turn like what
are we looking at front leg
it takes
i would say maybe like around 30 hours
like just to beat the like
the story and if you want to do more
probably take like 40 50 hours okay okay
this is the first time i've ever seen do
something zombie power yes which is
really cool no addict
let's look at the menus for a second i
want to see what's going on in the menu
system so we got our inventory now i see
the gas stuff okay can you break down
some of these items and why it would be
like useful to the player and just the
inventory system yeah yeah oh okay so
in addition to like health meter stamina
he has a
a hunger meter and a thirst meter okay
and yeah like if to feel the hunger
you're gonna have to eat food gotcha and
then to drink like drink the
the water it's fill your thirst
now all these things are resources you
can gather in the world or yeah also
okay now the other shopkeepers there are
some things you can buy from people or
mostly it's fully gathering within the
world
you
oh yeah if you go back to the farm
though you can farm zombies
to equip that's like minions to help
fight with you really yeah if we have
mdz zombies yeah i like that i like your
pieces
all right so we have a skill tree okay
range okay survival
so are there again with that craft what
about some of the different play styles
according to the skill tree that you can
kind of how do you gain the sp system
what do you see
every time you do quests or you just uh
gather items they always give you sp
gotcha
pretty cool pretty cool let's get back
to that gameplay though
yeah if you want to go home you can pick
up zombies and then like i can show you
like how how the zombies work
what's the direction to go home oh
yeah just uh up
oh oh
sorry the map is changing
if you go to this plot this is all the
zombies that like it's already like
farms foreign
so you could harvest the zombie parts
and then we could use these as minions
yeah this is hilarious what do we know
what is there a maximum amount that you
can have um in the inventory just like
it shows you like how many i don't i
don't remember the exact number
you hit the zombies
pretty much
yeah or it's most useful there but if
you go to the crafting shop you can use
the zombies to also make weapons if you
want so you don't necessarily have to
use the zombie themselves to fight
gotcha oh that's interesting that's
interesting that's really cool we got to
start us down here
we're checking out the stories checking
things out we got a crafting table we're
going to craft these zombie cards
together we got our guns
okay we got the weed rack and the home
gun y'all homemade gun
it's cool
by parts of the the combat there's also
like tower defense so like you would use
the the fence to block offs like the
enemies
set traps for them like to gotchu
but the question i was going to ask that
what about like in terms of bosses oh we
have any boss encounters in a dead crash
yeah like every every level of the city
you get into there's always like a boss
that you have to try to get further
cinematic making our weapons crafting
okay he's getting really into it very
serious about his crafting
he approves he approves of the craft so
we got the homemade gun all right oh
yeah then there's a section to make like
zombie items as well
and like all the heat you gotta get up
you gotta get you got to get the
seatbelt chunk and we gotta get the
undead lab go back go back to the undead
drink we gotta get your energy drink you
gotta get your monster and now this is
how you uh uh farm the zombies like all
the humans that you kill if you kill
them and like pick up their corpse you
can i'm done
yeah
that's an interesting game
you're a very interesting game
you don't need a card man yeah this this
is this this is really cool
dead craft so again
just for emphasis as far as availability
what are we looking at dead craft
uh it comes out uh may 19th may 19th
again with all the platforms looking
really cool
a lot a lot of complex layers to it i
think it's an exciting title to watch
man addict do you approve that crap
no they had to go somewhere
that's how much attic approved so look
at it here first the the shooting feels
nice too oh we got a little gunplay okay
okay
i like the little the animations looks
really tight yeah right
oh we're popping hey but we popping
heads out here
really cool
yeah and then i guess in terms of
different play styles you were asking
about yeah all the weapons play a little
differently the only thing that that i
don't like too much is like the lock-on
system i feel like
it's still good so we gotta lock one
system is it like
latched on over here yeah i like it i
really do addict approves man
got our alert system
so if you picked up a zombie you can um
i'm curious can we utilize the dog for
something
oh yeah if you still like the zombies
yeah i keep pressing v for the switch
yeah yeah
so yeah i push push x and then you can
just place them and they kind of just
follow oh
oh there you go wait so what was the dog
about we do anything with that
yeah what's up with that
that's a rat like he you just use that
to pick up to eat for free oh okay
scavenge yeah in case you can't like
when you don't have money like you can't
buy food at the shop then you're gonna
have to okay so we could just really eat
okay
get our corpse on i just want to see one
fight with him in this this little
minion he's being i want you these
minions do yeah that's like the one
benefit of like killing a human like if
you see like a tough like human you want
to create as a zombie yeah
oh there you go they're going to move
this is hilarious
that is cool you got your random npcs
you got your little zombies you got your
crafting looking really cool y'all dead
crafts again all players platforms may
19th again an absolute pleasure looking
forward to learning more about this game
lord addict approves the lord out of
approval it's a good deal it's a good
deal so that's what you got here
pinellas podcastinggaming.net
dead craft y'all
[Music]
you